three letters to the Prime Minister
signed by more than a hundred groups and
individuals all condemning the words of
his Home Secretary soella bravaman just
nine days ago what we've seen is a
practice whereby uh vulnerable White
English girls being
pursued and raped and drugged and harmed
by gangs of British Pakistani men
in response groups representing health
and business organizations as well as
Community leaders have come together
writing three letters which call those
comments appalling they accuse her of
stereotyping and targeting an entire
community and they also refer to home
office research that's found abusers
like this are most commonly white with
no ethnic group disproportionately
overrepresented what we would like
immediately we would like to withdrawal
of this statement Muslims in this
country are just coming out being very
synonymous with the word terrorism this
is actually going back to square one and
starting all over again where people
will wake up and think about when they
think about issues like parent sexual
exploitation the next name linked to
that would be British pakistanis a home
office spokesperson said all Despicable
child abusers must be brought to Justice
adding in towns like Rochdale Rotherham
and Telford can cultural sensitivities
meant thousands of young girls were
abused adding they've announced a raft
of measures including mandatory
reporting and a new police task force
that final policy was announced only
last week by the Prime Minister on a
visit to Rochdale at his side the Home
Secretary whose comments on British
pakistanis he's now being urged to
clarify and condemn Rachel Venable's Sky
News